dude that house is giving away full-size
candy bars that house forgave my student
loan debt what the hell kind of street
is
[Music]
this I'll give you the rest when you
retire are you a real woman did you get
the student loan thing kind of they said
the house on the right made them stop
using the front door so I had to go to
the back door and I only got 10K because
I don't work in the public well the
house on the right gave me an AR-15 holy
crap but they made me burned my library
card something about drag queens that
old guy on the left makes you sit
through Dei training and then takes half
your candy if he thinks you have too
much doesn't that guy own like three
houses yeah and all his candy has
stickers that say it may cause cancer
that guy on the right took away my Mikes
these things there a slippery slope to
Three Musketeers I've seen a ton of
AirHeads and Dum Dums on the far left
there's a huge Horror Show going on on
the right too but those guys are having
trouble with their speaker every new
one's worse than the last that red house
only gives out candy if you pass a drug
test oh wait did you get drugs not good
ones but the one on the far left gave me
hormone
blockers